教員間6個も持ち上げている多分私が一番多く用いられた自信ある五員環6個はすごい
な
僕はなくすので言うにもありませんこんにちははじめちゃうんですあの男性も女性もな
んですけども夜道を一人で歩いてるとやっぱ不思議車
危ない人とかスカートか突然襲ってきたりこんな風なあってはいけないんですけども
やっぱりどうしても一人で歩いてると狙われやすいんですよねそんな不審者から
ストーン
方が危険な人から身を守るのは自分しかいないときは自分だけなんでそんな自分のため
に護身用のアイテムがたくさん
2つと色々買ってみたんですけどもこちらですハーイちょっと選りすぐり度八尾ですね
amazon で6種類見つけてみました俺のどれかを持っていればその純部分のみは
何か誰も守られるんじゃないかなと思ったグッズでございますではさっそく見ていき
ましょう
ならやばいのかあったんだよなぁこれですね
エロいでつでも見るからにヤバさなんですけどこれ何でしょう増え
上かこっちなんすかねこういうのです
[音楽]
ハーフね音出すがすごい大事ですね
防犯月にも音出るなら防犯ブザーのあるねこれで音を出しつつ俺安全もさせようですね
これ
ギターこれやばいん
どうやってもちゃうけどタクティカルスティックっていうものでございます
めっちゃくちゃ痛いでちょっと1回実践してみましょうどうぞ
me
ポップン
ooooooooooooooooooooo oooo
プープー
おっ
[音楽]
none
うわぁ
きっと言う
うえーん
ちょっとあったんですえっ
聞いた水ではこちらですアーマーリングはっはっは
これやばいやいややばやばいでしょ
んうわぁインターってことでさせだけど見たいなこれ
めっちゃんこ遺体はこれ普通にして社員だら工作っている時もめちゃくちゃ痛そうです
ね安芸南が自然なキャリーで攻撃できるのは凄いです
これや使用した撃退候補こちらですどうぞ
me
ポップン
おおーー
プープー
4分
[音楽]
です
w どっち
[音楽]
えっ
ズーのこちらですはい小さ
やってーはいこちら時短爪楊枝ですパッドにこっちは戻りけど怖いパッと見声めっちゃ
小さい規模なんですけども来いってやるとカリが出てくるとこれあぶねー
いたっち誤審というちょっと行き過ぎただけですね普通に気がしちゃいますねには物騒
で水中での護身用とにあった広津んだよなぁこれで切ったりするとこんな感じになり
ますどうぞ
me
ポップン
おおーー
プープー
4校
[音楽]
バッハでちゃ
me
[拍手]
次はこちらです見た目がかっこいいですね
ん
何なんだ fcp 敵を傷つけず無力化する目的で世界の特殊部隊と共同開発された
febd 弊社の hp 全く分かりませんねた敵を無力化するらしいですエースに
誤審と思うんですねちょあげる日を大
見た目めっちゃかっこいいじゃあ舞台表な物品であるんですけどいつかんだろうな
リングに夕日
ok を目指すできる勲功ですねこれでここで小
ずっとやっ
最悪にいたそうだたしけでも傷つきませんからね相手にイタリアてるだけなんでは無力
化するという意味でもあってるんでしょうけど仏祖撃退方法をこんな感じになります
どうぞ
goo
おおーー
を
ん
goo
[音楽]
ですねえっ
いやーこちらです若干ちょっとネタに走ってるからたら普通にならヤバそうだった
うわぁ床の声を書いてありますね鉄線デス pets の多いと書いてる鉄製
うわぁ
ちゃんとつ星3+寿司熾烈でできている扇なんかめっちゃんこ思い出多いってなんか
普通に仰げばだけだと思うんですけどもて生は思い出
いったんっこれですよ
goo
非常にて製武器じゃないんみるんでこんなおいでて悪いとしたところを倒すとか
濃いいこれなかなか名義で使えそうですね実践動画どうぞ
me
分
おおーー
を取っ
[音楽]
ana
[拍手]
ん
最後はこちらですね催涙スプレーでございます
ここはサイレースウェイ違うってんだね穴豚であぶな
を描くモデル売ってるボレーショ本当に声
をする
ここはこんな勢いで出る5列止まってえーっ
んわれん
これここにいるだけをロードミュージックなんですけどばいいじゃんあーこれ
ってうまい
安い御魅力ですね
はい直接に投げてもすごいはい今日受けるんですけど早速時点で撮りました
どうぞ
ああああああ
ポップン
おおーー
プープー
おっ
[音楽]
ません
あっはぁ
穴塞いでるぞめ開ければ良いそれでいたい
以下が遅れていますよという
月や口もや歯に詰まっている
[音楽]
やばいあって月多くあっあっバージョンん
おっちゃん強いはっはっはっは
[音楽]
ちょ